[Music]
um nice to meet you all I'm happy that
there's so much interest here like the
room is completely packed if it were up
to me we just stay in the auditorium
then we also have more comfortable
chairs but uh I'm not the one deciding
so welcome my name is b f I'm one of the
co-founders of our company lay Dynamics
and I'm also a PhD student here at
University in aov and today I will be
talking about the new kind of AI brain
inspired natural Ai and we're going to
figure out okay what does it take to
make real intelligent
systems ready so that's enough about me
um I was also kind of curious about who
are we actually who am I talking to
today so I asked my personal assistant
like what can you tell me about the p P
data audience here in this
room and my assistant nicely replied
well the Pata conference Bo an
enthusiastic blend of python and data
Enthusiast from seasoned expert to Ego
newcomers it's a dynamic hub for
knowledge exchange and excitement about
The Cutting Edge developments in the
data real does that sound about right J
GPT knows
right but it was also a small remark but
be careful of the person in the white
shirt in the front left here or she
seems psych a critical person so not
sure which side left but uh let's keep
the questions to the end
perfect it's also the first almost the
first talk in the morning so I can
imagine that you're still a bit sleepy a
bit down so um I also asked okay how can
we wake everyone up how can we make sure
that everyone is fully present here in
this
room and also chpt came up with some
nice suggestions so um and entic music
we can do some physical
activities the room is a bit small so
what I asked it is okay what if I
promise you all coffee afterwards and
apparently that's also a great idea so
let's do that and um after this dog
we'll grab a coffee and then we have
some nice chats welcome
also it's quite impressive this chat GPT
it's actually very cool so if you have a
look and how quickly chat GPT was
adopted by almost everyone around the
world
then it's a bit too enthusiastic then it
only took five days for CET GPT to reach
a million users a million people
actually making use of this service in
comparison Instagram it took like 75
days and Spotify 150 so it's impressive
that this chat GPT kind of conquered the
world just 5 days to reach a million
users and and this goes on quite quickly
right so I'm not sure how many people
are using it right now I think please
raise your hand if you've used it
perfect so everyone knows that it's
really cool and that's also um very nice
to work
with even my parents are now asking hey
BX this J GPT uh should I know this what
can I use this for will it benefit
me for them it doesn't
but they are asking and for my parents
that's already quite a big step to get
in touch with this kind of uh yeah with
this kind of
Technology but with chipd did we unlock
through intelligence so we've all used
it we try to push its boundaries but
there are of course also limitations
right uh to give also some other
examples on from from works that are out
there this is like a image promt that
was generated I think it's like a year
ago so
where we asked
the I think the button is stuck or
something okay where we asked is to
generate some images of a salon in a
river and you get these very nice
pictures but it's exactly not what you
want like maybe for michelan dining this
would be nice that you have like a river
and you can actually eat the salmon
there but this is not what we intended
so it's
doing a great job but it's also uh yeah
I wouldn't call it intelligent and there
is also this very cool uh I think I
think it was funny came across it lately
so it's this Robot vacuum and it sends
this message to the user hey I'm I'm
stuck at a cliff
well bit metric if you dramatic if you
ask me so it's very cool very cool AI we
can do a lot of things but it's also
still limited to a certain
extent is it then really
intelligent we think it isn't because
generative AI s CH GPT has also some
pitfalls for example it's not really
adaptable so uh we know that it keeps on
training and it does its thing but it's
not really encountering data as it goes
along it's trained on like the entire
internet that was its training set and
then based on that it tries to make good
predictions it tries to engage you in
this conversation but as soon as
something new arrives it's kind of
struggling with
adapting yeah it's also intelligence
goes automatically furthermore jgpt for
example generative they usually blackbox
systems if you ask someone H what's
actually
inside no one knows they have some
intuition on how it works and how or how
this actually uh manages to still
generate some nice promts but actually
how it works in detail it's very
difficult and that also brings us kind
of to the last point so it's very
resource hungry I looked it up yesterday
and GPT 4 although exact numbers are not
known it's estimated to have like a
trillion
parameters that's quite insane right so
um maybe polars can also help us with
loading these trillions parameters
uh but it's a lot and also energy
consumption is also quite significant
not only for training because training
itself cost like millions of dollars uh
but also just like running it like we're
melting away the polar caps and I think
that's something that we don't want but
just fuing these data centers so these
are kind of some limitations of the AI
that we currently
know so what's up
next
well maybe the true the key to True AI
is given by this person so this person
on the right is called friston he's
renowned
neuroscientist stationed at Lon in
London and he has some ideas on how true
AI actually should work how this can be
really
intelligent um and he has developed this
concept called a free energy principle
sounds very theoretical so far it kind
of is but it talks about how uh
autonomous agent or person or being how
it should interact with its environment
in order to really enforce in
intelligent behavior and also to survive
because in the end for some kind of
autonomous uh being survival is one of
the few
goals and he talks about a couple of
properties that these agents or systems
should adhere to so first first of all
they should be able to learn online so
jgpt was trained on the entire internet
let's say but actually that's something
we don't we do not want we want it to
incorporate like a stream of
data and that it then can learn whil
it's going to give a simple example if
you were to ride a bike right if you
want to ride a bike you're not going to
watch documentaries at the age of three
or four five six um you're not going to
watch hours of documentaries oh
if I do this then uh I fall down and no
just going to hop on going to try
experience
so that's kind of also what this true AI
or this intelligent AI should adhere
to furthermore you also want it to be
explainable so as I talked about these
blackbox models we have no idea what's
going on
there but in a sense if we are thinking
about intelligent systems then we should
be able to decompose them we should be
able to uh explain how they are behaving
why they come up with certain
reasoning under this free energy
principle that this guy call friston
advocates he says that these systems
should adhere to a sense of
logic in our case we talk usually about
probability Theory because these capture
the
formalisms of actually human Logic on
how we perceive things and how we
interact with our environment
and furthermore we want it to be energy
efficient so um we want it for example
to be able to multitask like we humans
are capable of doing a lot of things at
once although performance in these Stars
slowly deteriorates as soon as you start
doing more at
once and the current systems are focused
on one task
specifically so with these three kind of
properties we hope to develop an
intelligent form of artificial
intelligence
and that's on this free energy principle
so throughout the entire history we have
come across a variety of fields so we
have the signal processing communication
control theory robotics machine learning
and all of these people these Brilliant
Minds have brought forward equations
which we used and we thought was very
relevant just out of curiosity who knows
three of these
equations
who knows
four is there also someone who knows all
five familiar with all
five very impressive so on the left we
have the actually um the foer transform
which decomposes a Time domain signal
into its frequency components in high
and low pitches we have our entr or our
Channel capacity how many bits can we
send over a specific transmission
Channel
in control the we have our colal filter
how do we
incorporate uh observations which have a
certain uncertainty about them we have
the famous Bellman equation Robert
Richard Bellman and the last one is very
famous machine learning back propagation
or the chain
rule but what we what turns out is this
natural AI that uh this free energy
principle actually we can phrase all of
these different things in terms of
minimization of the free energy so
actually free energy is all you
need and that makes this also very
attractive so if we develop a true kind
of intelligence then it would mean that
there is only one thing that we're going
to optimize only one thing that's at the
core let's say at the core of an
intelligent human agent namely this free
energy and with with that we can
discover the algorithms developed in the
past and we can phrase them as
such so let me introduce to you the
Gardner hype cycle it's called so
Gardner is a very
um pretty wellknown consultancy firm in
the in uh in the technology business and
every year they publish kind of their
hype cycle which demonstrates the
maturity of a certain type of uh
technology so all the way on the right
we have computer vision so we're quite
far with this we know what we can do and
that's already quite a
lot um and we kind of have reached the
plateau like everyone knows it's there
we're all using it it's very
cool but that's that autonomous vehicles
they were at some point very popular and
then kind of popularity decreased but
now we're getting to the point where
it's actually being used also in
Industry so you have these self-driving
taxis for example in some places around
the world already so we're slowly
getting
there all the way on the top we have
generative AI like chat
GPT a lot of expectations but we don't
really see this back into industry
yet so where's natural AI so with lay
Dynamics natural AI is actually still
here in the beginning so it's uh
undergoing research and development in
order to bring it also to industry but
it's still very novel very new and no
one is actually or almost no one is
working on this particular
topic for computer vision and generative
eye in order to make their advances
possible we had like amazing software
toolboxes so we know for example open CV
is for computer vision was widely used
uh for generative AI T of flow pytorch
garos all these kinds of software
packages and they have made these
Technologies to where they are today
they have made it that everyone can now
work with generative I just go on
YouTube Type in some words you can train
your own neural network let's
say but for natural AI this is still
missing we do not have software that
actually allows us to create real
intelligence
and that's where lace Dynamics comes in
so with this La Dynamics we try to
bridge the gap from the kind of
theoretical research that gois and
Advocates to actually industry
applications and the way that we do this
is with our uh toolbox written also by
Dimitri and other members of our team uh
got RX infer and what it does it
automates the minimization of free
energy
so this thing that we needed to minimize
to get through intelligent Behavior
that's what this toolbox
automates and why is that very nice if
we have for example a company called
room by Inc and they want to make
adaptive and also collaborative Robot
vacuum cleaners they have this certain
problem and what we do with lay Dynamics
is we build a specific model for them
which is interpret able explainable can
learn and adapt
online and then in this model we do this
reasoning this uh this logic and we
automate this with our toolbox RX
infer and if we do this we end up with
the new generation of Ro um Robot vacuum
cleers doesn't sound too impressive of
course but the same holds for another
company drones Incorporated who wants to
make adaptive and collaborative Dr
drones the only thing that changes in
the story is our model we make a model
that's our that's drone specific
explainable uh
adaptive and then again we run inference
with our toolbox we automate it just
like tensor flow does or pytorch does on
the models machine learning models that
are used
today and with that we can build yeah a
new generation of
Thrones very short introduction of what
we're doing
um if you're interested please check us
out on L dynamics.com
I would also love to talk to you
afterwards like um I have to leave after
lunch so if there are a lot of questions
just please reach out to me during the
coffee
breaks also check out a toolbox it's on
GitHub it's in Julia although we're in
by data of course there are excellent
Julia rappers so n left I would
recommend checking it out RX
in.ml
um ah and of course we're going to grab
some coffee afterwards thanks a lot for
your attention it was a pleasure being
here very full room good that you're
enthusiastic and if you want to know
more of course just reach out to me
afterwards um and then I would like to
give the floor for some questions thank
[Applause]
you
yes you talk a lot
about you talk a lot about generative AI
but you didn't mention reinforcement
learning and also reinforcement learning
is similar in the sense that there is a
a reward optimization function that you
want to either maximize or minimize the
question is where does it stand compared
to this natural AI because what natural
AI does is very similar to agents which
are actually intelligence and generative
AI is not about intelligence it's about
coping reinforcement is about adapting
to the environment
second question is where that bias comes
into the play because uh you didn't
explain why uh uh B probability enters
into the game of natural AI as you call
it very good questions thanks a lot um
so maybe the critical person was
actually here and not in the the front
left but very good so with regards to
reinforcement learning so there I agree
it's a very cool field and you
completely right so they try to learn
through experiences but they're also
quite often relatively inefficient in
doing so so if you have a simple model
it takes a huge amount of Trials just to
get up and
running um with this natural form of AI
is that we we do not only want to
optimize this reward function but at the
same time we want to make yeah we want
to learn right we don't just want to
exploit this reward function but we also
want to kind of
explore we want to explore what's what's
around there what's uh what useful
States might actually lead to a benefit
in obtaining this
reward so in a sense natural AI can be
phrased as or I would say it the other
way around reinforcement learning can be
phrased as also this free energy
minimization the thing is that re um
natural AI shines in this element
because it's not only exploitative so it
doesn't only optimize this value
function but it's also explorative so it
tries to gain as much information as
possible
and then with regard to your second
question um I didn't touch a lot about
this indeed probability Theory and bias
and all that kind of stuff because I
thought it would be a bit much for this
uh 10:00 10:00
talk but what we tried to do is we try
the models to become like adaptive that
they learn online and in a sense they
will Dev they might develop a bias if
they are just in one situation they
might develop a bias for that particular
situation but that's it's not a problem
because they're also adaptive so if you
move to a different environment then we
want the model in a sense to recognize
oh I actually don't know this out of
distribution some people might call it
and then we want the model to adapt to
this situation in the end we want models
to also grow over time so instead of
having a static model that we try to fit
all our data on we want a model that
grows depending on the needs and on the
task at hand and also on the environment
and in a sense that alleviates this this
bias problem
yeah is that clarify yeah this another
question more about the way that things
learn because if I have a reinforcement
learning agent I will explore the space
if I have some given distribution I will
explore the space one example at a time
when if about bias I can imagine that
there is some even prior and then
instead of exploring one single data
point and collected data point sort of
M have a distribution function and they
try to Maxim minimize
overal
ofation kind of what what you
said yeah so the thing is we try to keep
away and refrain from uh from samping
because it's it's slow to just pick out
one of the points um instead we do
something in a very modular fashion we
do this free energy minimization uh by
something
message passing a bit extreme but
basically what it does it does
probability Theory but then very
localized so that we can create modular
structures where each local part still
obeys the rules of probability Theory um
regarding the other points I think we
should have a chat afterwards because
it's uh to be quite in depth but I like
uh yeah I like the thoughts thank
you
in what way does this uh open up the
black
box in a sense that we can build the
models ourselves so it becomes very easy
to incorporate model specific knowledge
domain specific knowledge in our models
of course we can also do something
similar with with machine learning or
deep learning networks um but this yeah
we can specify the model ourselves if
there are things for
example if we talk about audio
processing just to give a rough example
we know that our brain how it does this
it has these auditory cortexes on the
somewhere next to your air canal and
they perform kind of a frequency
decomposition of your signal this is
something that you can insert already in
your model and use this information
whereas the actual audio processing I
have no idea what's going on my head
sometimes I'm also asking this
so in in a sense explainable means to me
that we can make a clear distinction
between the parts that are model based
and also things that we just don't know
and we want to want to learn over
time um nonetheless if
we say to say it very bluntly if we just
insert a huge
model we still want to know which part
of this model are actually relevant and
we have done some research on this and
also quite interesting works so um what
we did is we built like a basan neural
network it's just neural network with
priors and probability Theory and we
checked okay can we get rid of Weights
because our model at like 600 parameters
not that much but for a certain TS it
turned out that we can reduce this model
down to just two
parameters so if we have ch GPT GPT 4
with like say a trillion maybe only a
million of them are relevant that's
something we don't know so in a sense
this explainability comes in one form
that we have a model based structure but
also in a sense that we can figure out
which part of the model are actually
relevant um to the TOs that we're
solving but but then still a model of U
of 600 parameters would still be complex
to
grasp that's true but sometimes you need
uh you need yeah you don't know how
certain type of processing comes along
so uh yeah blackbox models are still
useful not denying that but we should
get yeah more explainability into them
thanks guys uh thanks a lot thanks a lot
B and I think that there are plenty more
questions but uh I would like to just uh
thank
[Music]
him